[Music]
[Music]
patch notes for phase 1 of the season 10
pts have just been released and while
nothing we see here is 100 final they
still give us a very good understanding
of what additional aspects on top of the
manhunt to expect in the upcoming season
pts's are here for us to test and
attempt to break before the final
product was released in the main game so
as per expected some of what i talk
about here has potential to change
depending on how things play out
the new countdown difficulties will be
available to try out normal for solo
which i'm actually happy about because i
can explore the map a little better i've
been doing it on the existing mode solo
but this is obviously a bit more
difficult this also opens it up to solo
players who don't wish to join a
matchmade team to be able to utilize the
area for the fantastic targeted loot
drops towards the expertise progression
there is also hard for groups of eight
casual players
i don't see this one being hugely
popular
challenging which is actually the
current difficulty we play countdown on
and heroic which is best suited for 4-8
hardcore players hopefully the loop
quality will be significantly increased
for that last one
the new challenges or counter measures
will also be added
skill suppression explosive resistance
reload speed armor protection hostile
skill damage resistance
agents hazard resistance
headshot resistance critical resistance
all of these countermeasures honestly
don't really mean much to me
the current countermeasures don't really
impact the game at all i can't think of
a time where they have impacted the way
i play the game when rushing through
this timed mode with seven other players
guns are blazing at all times
it might be a little different on heroic
but these are just slight increases or
decreases on damage resistance or
abilities
obviously balancing needs to be taken
into consideration but i'd like to see
some more impactful and interesting
countermeasures that change the way you
need to play
take the global events for example
imagine the enemies have the golden
bullet within their ranks and the
deactivation benefit gives us the
opportunity to gain the golden bullet
now i'm not saying this is the best
example i'm just saying that something
other than decreasing your crit chance
or ability to heal could be a bit more
entertaining to play through at this
stage if they removed counter measures
all together i don't know if they'd even
notice
other changes they're trying out is a
way to prevent players from being kicked
out of the group by the group leader
before and during the extraction
something that is well overdue however
i'd love to see the ability before the
mode even begins to group vote on a new
leader if they haven't started the damn
game already
archibus brassos
sorry to any spanish-speaking listeners
for my pronunciation but this is a new
gear brand set
one piece gives 10 skill haste cool
two pieces give one skill tear sweet
three pieces give 20 ammo capacity
huh
i don't really get it most skill builds
are either lurking from outside
providing support or skill damage while
their weapons are important to increase
the effectiveness of their skills weapon
capacity has never really been seen as
an issue though this might be a sign of
a weapon or weapon talent that is yet to
be released
umbra initiative gear set
two pieces plus 15 critical charts three
pieces plus 30 reload speed
four pieces give access to two unique
talents based on the player positioning
from the shadows and into the light
from the shadows while in cover gain 10
stacks per second up to 50 each stack
will give one percent critical damage
increase and 0.5 rpm
buff does not apply while shooting from
cover
while out of cover you lose 4 stacks per
second at normal speed and 2 stacks per
second if running
enter the light while out of cover and
in combat gain 10 stacks per second up
to 50. each stack will give you 0.5
armor regen when it is consumed stacks
consume 10 stacks per second only in
cover
the chest in the backpack of the set
increases the stacks from 50 to 100
this is going to be an absolute beast
gear set in my opinion maybe not for
players who are out there with full
squads but for solar players like myself
increased damage and healing depending
on agent stance sounds pretty good to me
but i might need to have a good play
around with this and see how viable it
actually is in action
on paper though it sounds pretty
interesting
exotics
doctor home an exotic variation of the
m1a
shooting an enemy with the doctor home
applies a mark when killed mark target
drops a 50 armor repair kit
the kit doesn't give bonus armor only
the weapon owner can see the armor
repair kit once the player picks up the
armor kit all party members receive the
heal we don't know the damage of this
weapon yet but based on the talent alone
this could be an interesting addition
for a support player
it doesn't appear to need the wielder to
kill the target just hit it so i can
imagine the user to be spamming the
weapon around and collecting the armor
kits while the dps members are taking
the enemies down
bloody knuckles exotic gloves
throwing a grenade or striking an enemy
with a melee attack activates the seeing
red buff
seeing red grants 25 weapon damage and
100 middle-e damage
seeing reed lasts 20 seconds and has a
60-second cooldown
while in cooldown striking an enemy with
a merely attack or hitting an enemy with
the effect of a grenade will complete
the cooldown instantly
anyone who has teamed up with me knows i
like to be upfront and in the thick of
it hell i even designed a sniper build
that allows me to use it up close and
personal
this particular exotic piece intrigues
me not necessarily because of the melee
damage increase though this is a nice
addition when resetting the cooldown but
because my need to be so close will
actually be rewarded
i already have a couple of builds that i
can see this being useful in
busy little b exotic pistol
each shot to a different target
increases weapon damage if the player
keeps shooting at different targets
each shot increases 10 to a maximum of
200 percent
players have five seconds to shoot
between each target until they lose the
stacks and must start again
when the time is over or the player
shoots the same target they will gain an
extra 5 damage for each stack they were
able to get on the next shot
the stacks will remain even if the user
changes weapons
[Music]
five seconds isn't very long but i'm
interested to try this out
i'm a big fan of sidearm talents i
actually have set my mouse to allow for
faster switching between my main weapons
and sidearm but i'm skeptical as to
whether this will be adjusted into the
ground following the pts or if the time
limit is just too low to be viable in
most situations
named weapons
lefty
12 shotgun and stage left socom m1a
rifle
these both have the perfect sleep
chamber talent
dealing damage with a grenade applies a
mark on the target
targets with marks take 40 more damage
to armor and minus movement speed
grenades are more of an addition to the
way i play not a focus i'm sure there
will be builds that make this viable but
i don't really see this as a talent that
i'll often use
as per usual there are a number of
quality of life changes that are being
added
i'm not going to read through them but
i'll chuck them on the screen there
isn't anything major to talk about here
but i see a couple of pet peeves being
addressed that a number of people will
be happy to see like the option to hide
loot beams and the added character
customization allowing players to change
body type skin tone and face shape after
starting the character progression
rather than being forced to start a new
character
i need to remind you that everything
featured here is for the upcoming pts
for season 10 and is subject to change
also if you are planning on taking part
in this a number of the new models and
gear will only have placeholders for now
the final art is yet to be confirmed
the preload will be available on august
18th at 1800 cest and will be live on
friday the 19th with the exact times to
be confirmed
something else i didn't mention is that
the new legendary strongholds at tuttle
basin and national zoo will also be
included
i don't usually try the pts's out but
after the last one i really felt i was
able to provide some solid feedback and
some of what i've seen echoed and
actioned over time so i'll definitely be
jumping into this one and i'll fully be
keeping up to date with my thoughts
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]